je force vous avez annoncé il y a
quelques mois une baisse de vos taux de
frais Dans le but de contribuer à
l'effort de modération des prix à la
consommation des Outre-mer un an
auparavant vous aviez pris la décision
d'appliquer un gel des taux de fret à
destination des Outre-mer je dois
reconnaître que ce sont des efforts
louables mais suscite toutefois de
questions de ma part sans vouloir
remettre en cause votre modèle
économique devant nous croire que les
taux pratiqués auparavant étaient
excessifs ou avait été excessif aussi je
sais pas pour les autres territoires
même si je rejoins ma collègue Catherine
Concorde mais je crois pas avoir
constaté les conséquences de vos efforts
au niveau des prix pratiqués dans les
commerces j'admets que vous n'êtes pas
les mieux placés pour m'apporter une
réponse pour cette deuxième question
mais je tenais néanmoins à l'évoquer
comme la fait tout à l'heure Catherine
le panier des ménages est très important
pour nous et on se rend compte que nos
compatriotes en tout cas nos ménagères
souffrent justement par rapport à ces
tarifs par rapport au fret et
au gel des frettes et euh à l'annonce
des 750 euros pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée sur la Guyane 750 euros sur un
fret aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 20%
des fois sur le fret
vous pourriez me dire bah pourquoi on
retrouve pas cet effort sur à la vente
ensuite par contre par 40 pieds
sur la goutte sur la Guadeloupe ou sur
la Martinique c'est un peu plus c'est à
peu près 30% parce que le taux de fret
sur la Guyane c'est un peu plus cher que
sur la Guadeloupe de par la difficulté
on va dire d'aller desservir ce
territoire
donc quand même cet effort du groupe il
est il est réel il existe chaque semaine
chaque conteneur qui charge aujourd'hui
pour les départements d'outre-mer
bénéficient des 750 euros cet argent on
le donne sera belle il existe on le fait
et ça ça dure depuis déjà maintenant le
premier août donc on est maintenant au
mois de février et force cette constaté
malheureusement que vous ne voyez pas
vous ne voyez pas de baisse
des prix de vente dans les magasins et
vous voyez noter quand même que nous en
tant qu'acteur de cette de cette baisse
c'est quand même monsieur Saad qui a
pris cette décision je rappelle que
c'est il l'a pris seul c'est nous sommes
le seul armateur à l'avoir fait
aujourd'hui on est quand même assez
frustré de voir qu'il y a pas grand
chose qui a avancé finalement et que
quand on va devoir réinjecter ces 750
euros parce que ça a une fin tout ça le
31 juillet 2023 j'aimerais que
j'aimerais pas qu'on nous dise bah on va
augmenter les prix devant parce que
finalement grâce à ces 750 euros on a pu
faire baisser les prix alors qu'ils
n'ont pas baissé moi j'ai longuement
discuté avec les préfets notamment pour
essayer de comprendre pourquoi
aujourd'hui cette baisse on aura pas
si le finalement le transport maritime
et si important si le prix du transport
maritime et déterminant aujourd'hui dans
le prix de vente d'un produit pourquoi
aujourd'hui ça se voit pas sur le paquet
de pâtes pourquoi ça se voit pas donc
c'est tout c'est toute cette situation
qui nous frustre un petit peu
aujourd'hui comme vous pour lesquels il
y a cet effort qui est fait on n'a pas
de réponse enfin en tout cas on le voit
pas et c'est malheureux je suis désolé
de vous le dire c'est malheureux et j'en
suis j'en suis très fier grâce aux
équipes et grâce également à nos équipes
en Guyane et à tous nos collègues
guyanais on va ouvrir à partir du 22
mars une escale à Saint-Laurent de
maronis nous allons aller à
saint-laurent-de-maronis le 22 mars
c'est c'est nouveau
saint-laurent-de-maroni c'est l'ouest de
la Guyane on sait qu'il y a un
développement important au niveau
démographique on sait qu'il y a des
entreprises qui s'installent on sait
qu'il y a
des importations qu'on pourrait passer
par Saint Laurent le problème c'est que
Saint-Laurent de Maroni c'est un port
fluvial et il y a 4 mètres d'eau
voilà donc on a on sait qu'on a des
contraintes portuaires compliquées mais
on va essayer de le faire sachant qu'en
Guyane déjà aujourd'hui en Guyane a
dégrade des cannes quand vous voulez
escaler vous n'avez que 6 mètres 52 et
vous travaillez avec des grues de bord
vous n'avez pas d'infrastructures
portières vous n'avez pas de portique
vous n'avez pas de grue donc on va on va
faire cette première escale à
saint-laurent-de-maronis et on va
pouvoir donc développer développer ce
lien régional et même pouvoir aller
offrir une solution à l'importateur
guyanais dans l'Ouest guyanais au lieu
de faire du camion entre Cayenne et
Saint-Laurent le Maroni il pourra
importer directement sur Saint-Laurent
j'espère que la première escale va bien
se passer
et je pense que c'est le début d'une
belle aventure si on réussit à
faire à faire nos escales sans sans
difficulté merci pour l'Ouest guyanet
oui effectivement il y a une démographie
galopante puis en fait ça Laurent
deviendra très bientôt la deuxième la
première capitale en fait puisque c'est
Cayenne mais avec sa démographie et avec
toutes les activités ben c'est Laurent
deviendra la capitale de la Guyane